für diese aufgabe einer ersten
positionierung stand gestern und so neue
außenministerin annalena baerbock als
sie in moskau war vorher war sie in kiew
der hauptstadt der ukraine und bild
fragt nach was steckt hinter dieser
reihenfolge und kann wer box so den
krieg verhindern uns zugeschaltet ist
jetzt beim stritzel der gestern live mit
der außenministerin vor ort war
sie hat sich aus deinen augen anna lena
berger gestern geschlagen
also das natürlich solche haltungsnoten
immer ein bisschen schwierig zu
beurteilen sind und man kann natürlich
auch mal nach der nach der
sinnhaftigkeit fragen dass dieses
eindrucks sehen sie nach außen
vermittelt wie man den bewährten möchte
aber ich glaube so nach den gängigen
kriterien war es ein ziemlich souveräner
auftritt den sie den sie da hingelegt
hat also sie hat sich nicht sie hat sich
nicht die show stehlen lassen von love
auf der ja vorher mal angekündigt wird
als harter hund als jemand der mit allen
wassern gewaschen sei und in diesem bild
des harten hundes des erfahrenen
diplomaten dass noch in der sowjetunion
geschulten außenpolitikers da sind
glaube ich ganz viele anteile terin die
die zumindest aktuell nicht mehr zu
treffen also ich glaube dass annalena
baerbock sich da sich da sehr gut
geschlagen hat schauen wir doch mal rein
kurz in den auftritt nach ihrem treffen
mit diesem so erfahrenen mit diesem
eiskalten
putin außenminister sergej lawrow auf
also ihr auftritt anna lena berger kurz
danach
in den letzten wochen haben sich mehr
als hundert tausend russische soldaten
mit panzern und geschützen der nähe der
ukraine versammelt ohne
nachvollziehbaren grund es ist schwer
das nicht als drohung zu verstehen
ja sagt dieser satz hat gesessen das war
ein treffer der war auf den punkt
formuliert bier und das ist auch ein
grund weswegen du sagst souveräner
auftritt gestern von unserer neuen
bundes außenministerin genau das war
nach einem gespräch das ursprünglich für
eine stunde angesetzt war mit sergej
lawrow und er hat dann deutlich
überzogen also das gespräch ging
deutlich über zwei stunden
das heißt sie hatte sie hat danach
diesem gespräch nach diesem sehr harten
gespräch wohl dass ich mit ihm geführt
hat sind beide vor die presse getreten
das war dann sehr konstant war sehr war
während der ihm während des auftritts
zunächst vor der presse sehr sehr
freundlich zurückhaltend und hat er
versucht sie so ein wenig zu umgarnen
und dann hat sie aber eigentlich sich
dann gar nicht gar nicht von tieren
lassen sondern hat eben also er hat auch
die ukraine nur relativ kurz
angesprochen und sie hat aber eben sehr
deutlich im punkt gemacht wie wir es
gerade gehört haben dass es eben eine
ganz klare drohung dass diese 100.000
soldaten dass man es nicht anders als
den als drohung verstehen kann
also gute noten von bieren stritzel der
gestern bei dem auftritt von annalena
baerbock dort in moskau dabei war es
eine schwierige aufgabe für sie werden
sie dabei ganz genau beobachtet und uns
aufgefallen an ihrem auge aber irgendwas
nicht okay kann es uns aufklären
er hat sie sich eine kinder heute zu
einem kurz zuvor zugezogen das ist
natürlich ein mal das klingt erstmal ein
bisschen lästigen lappalie und nicht
nicht mehr aber wenn man sich vorstellt
hat wahrscheinlich schon jeder mal das
ist natürlich etwas was jetzt nicht
unbedingt so gut ist für die
konzentration wenn man so in solchen
marathon tag also es war ein einziger
termin den sie an dem tag hatte aber
dass der wichtigste sozusagen und dann
über zwei stunden mit mit cgi worauf
dort dort verhandelt dann ist das
natürlich eine behinderung was
dem zuträglich ist das war kein blaues
auge dass sie sich in moskau geholt hat
sagt auch unser korrespondent pieren
stritzel der die neue außenministerin
dorthin in die höhle des bären begleitet
hat nein sie hat sich sehr souverän dort
geschlagen sagt er vergibt positive gute
noten für annalena baerbock danke bio
stritzel